So, what does the E state do?
The M state gives us exclusive access,
so we can both read and
write and
makes us the owner of a dirty block.
So, we have to respond with the data and
also update memory.
The S state gives us shared access so
that we can only read and
we are not responsible for
giving others our data and
also we are not responsible for
updating memory.
We have seen that the O state also give
us shared access so we can do reads.
But makes us responsible for updating
memory and giving data to others, so
that we avoid memory writes that
occur when we don't have the state.
What E does is it gives us exclusive,
so that we can read and
write, although
the block is still clean.
The memory still doesn't
need to be updated.
So when a core does read
A followed by Write A.
In the MSI protocol we move from
invalid to shared and suffer a miss,
and then we move from shared to modified
and need to send out an invalidation.
So we have two bus accesses.
If we have the MOSI
we have the same sequence because really
the O state is not helping us here.
It's helping us save memory accesses
after we had the write, and
others start reading.
If we have the MESI, with no O-state,
or a protocol that combines all
of the states, when we do a read,
we now detect that although we have read
the block, we're the only one having it.
So instead of going to the shared
state we go to the E state and
we suffer a miss.
But the VNR is that when a write
to A occurs we know we have
exclusive access so we can just write
without telling anybody although
we have to transition to the N state now
because now the block is also dirty.
So now we get the same
behavior that we would get
if we did this sequence of accesses
on a cache in a uniprocessor.
So this is not a shared block here, and
we want to get the same number of misses
and accesses as we do in a uniprocessor
that doesn't share data.
So here we will have a miss.
Followed by a cache hit.
We want to have a cache hit here and
the E state allows us to achieve that.